jour nuit jour nuit je conduis ouvert
terme est ouvert fermé ouvert terme'
[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui à paris on va les
voir aujourd'hui le mime x3000 x300 à
mon avis de téléphone de schumi qui va
déchirer de cette fin d'année alors pour
l'instant il n'est pas dispo en france
je vais faire un tour du côté de chez
hopscotch qui s'occupe des relations
presse de xiaomi france ils ont modèle
du mx3 qui en version chinoise à
l'inversion globale pour l'instant donc
malheureusement pas encore en france est
néanmoins on va aller le voir j'ai envie
de voir ce petit coup de folie sans voir
s'il est cool le prendre en main
découvrez quand même temps elle fait un
python tout et de chéops coach choralien
bonjour tout le monde voilà allez ça
c'est quand même très très grosse des
trophées fun radio du cinéma avatar
plateforme soit quoi méditer un petit et
on me donne alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
ici tu n'expliques l'instant c'est parti
alors ici on a le 1008 light qu'on va
tester d'ici quelques jours le mérite
light pour l'instant il est là il est
bon il ouvrira un peu plus tard quand on
sera au studio on à son grand frère le
mille huit pros donc c'est pareil ça on
va attendre d'être au studio pour
pouvoir l'ouvrir le tester version
globale tous à jouer je vous en parlais
d'ici quelques jours on a un stade
langonnais 845 moi y'a plein de choses
un écran de 6,21 pouces et sur le mythe
qu'il ait nos instincts dragon 660 un
écran de 6,26 poussera tout ça on va le
détailler d'ici quelques jours et en
attendant regardez qui voilà ça c'est
tant pis si ça c'est la boîte du mx3
temps là franchement ça change un peu
c'est vrai qu'on a pas plus de formats
de boîtes sur le mix de s j'aime bien ça
c'est les gants ça change par rapport à
ce cas sur le marché alors d'aller voir
ce qui à l'intérieur petit mot fort
sympathique merci beaucoup voilà ça
c'est cool smartphones on va le regarder
dans quelques instants on va le mettre
de côté voire un petit peu ce qui est un
peu l'intérieur de la boîte bon pour
l'instant comme on vous le dit c'est pas
du tout dispo encore en france mais ça
ne saurait tarder c'est donc de la
recharge sans fil
bon vous allez on a forcément des
adaptateurs qui n'est pas du tout
français mais bon c'est normal ici votre
câble avec de l'usb type c est là
dessous on en a un qu'on a laissé une
petite coque de kits doc et de quoi
ouvrir votre tiroir de cartes sim et
chan adaptateur usb tilt c'est vers
prise jack l'avait donc dire que nous
n'avons pas deux prises jack sur notre
mx3 alors modèle qui est présenté on
vraiment en avant-première parce que
pour l'instant il n'est pas du tout du
tout du tout dispo en europe dispo en
france il est uniquement dispo en chine
j'ai pas de bêtises en vrai que c'est sa
femme qui pousse pousse on l'a vraiment
en version qui pancrase version globale
qui est vraiment une toute première
version qui vient de chine il a pris
l'avion de chine paf il arrivait
directement ici shops coach strictement
impossible de le sortir de chez
hopscotch
ça tombe plutôt bien j'y suis donc comme
ça on va regarder ça ensemble on a ici
un double module photo à l'arrière
capteur d'empreintes digitales qu'on
voit ici de l'usb type c'est ici bouton
on/off bouton de volume sur le côté ici
vous avez un autre bouton je ne connais
pas encore la fonction tiroirs de cartes
sim sur le côté jour nuit
joe nuit sur des lits ouverts terme est
ouvert fermé pouvait refermer donc je
fais ça se met directement sur
l'appareil photo est bien petit bruit
sais pas si vous entendez j'adore c'est
vrai qu'on une sensation de robustesse
ça c'est vraiment un truc hyper
important parce que on se dit quand on
une partie mécanique comme ça quelque
chose de coulissante qui va bouger c'est
très important d'avoir vraiment une
bonne sensation de robustesse parce que
c'est truqué pas solides on se dit qu'au
bout d'un certain temps ça va forcément
se casser ce white ou un lock up afs est
parti on voit son écran de 6,39 pouces
de diagonale qui franchement plutôt bien
une définition de 2340 par 1080 pixels
pousse la luminosité à fond
franchement je trouve assez lumineux
alors il faudra faire des tests lorsque
je l'aurai décidé but 2019 en testant on
ira voir à l'extérieur ce qu'il est là
pour l'instant j'ai pas le droit de le
sortir de shops coach donc bon je peux
pas vraiment vous en dire plus mais en
tout cas un vaillant comme ça je trouve
plutôt bien puis en connaissant la
qualité des produits de stomie je pense
qu'il est vraiment très très bon en
termes de pertes et tente son instinct
dragon 845 cadencé jusqu'à 2,8 gigahertz
côté gpu c'est une adreno 630 vous avez
si giga de ram et il est dispo soit en
128 giga de stockage soit en 256 non
extensible vous avez ici votre tiroir de
cartes sim vous pouvez mettre une double
sim mais pas carte micro sd on a une
batterie de 3200 milliampères heures du
mans
tous 5.0 et pas deux prises jack c'est
un petit peu le côté un peu regret là
dessus mais bon allez on voit très bien
que les prises jack disparaissent de
toute façon en cette fin 2018 2019 ça va
continuer on va de plus en plus sur des
casques bluetooth donc c'est un peu la
fin de la prise jack sur les smartphones
phares aibaq sarah jamais attendent
était un jeu c'est un plusieurs heures
on a un double module photo l'arrière
deux fois 12 mégapixels f 1.8 pour l'un
et f 2.4 pour l'autre
le f 1.8 devrait être plutôt excellent
en faible luminosité tandis que lotz un
tel objectif à f 2.4 qui va vraiment
venir vous aider pour le mode portrait à
l'avant d'un double module photo caméra
principale de 24 mégapixels et la
deuxième caméra de 2 mégapixels qui va
venir vraiment travailler de concert
avec la 24 mégapixels pour le mode
portrait on peut filmer jusqu en 4k à 60
images par secondes plutôt cool on a
forcément de la stabilisation qu on a
donc de la vidéo de la photo le mode
portrait un mode nuit pendant un mois on
a du slow motion
on est soit en 120 fps 240 fps messieurs
dames qui dit mieux 960 as ps pouvait
filmer même en full hd en 960 fps on ça
c'est franchement plutôt cool lille est
dispo à priori en trois couleurs noir
bleu vert ici c'est la version bleue
alors avoir une foi qui sera présentée
en france expliqué des petits
changements là dessus là des petites
traces de doigts l'arrière mais bon
franchement c'est pas c'est pas déconner
on a bien évidemment la surcouche maison
de chaume islami white et qui tourne sur
un android spy 9.0 parle en terme de
points je trouve pas hyper hyper lourd
chez ces petits 218 g tranquillement
voilà le genre mans ça va ça va la prise
en main est vraiment bonne
on trouve très très facilement
l'emplacement du capteur d'empreintes
digitales bon ça c'est un grand
classique chez chuo minuit ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien le fait d'avoir cette
petite techno là pour venir
soit ils pêcheront ça vraiment très très
bon l'ouverture du clapet je peux clair
pendant des heures jour nuit jour nuit
jour nuit ils disent quoi 205 200 mille
fois trois cent mille fois cinq cent
mille fois trois cent mille fois mumbai
ces partis que tu a réservé pour combien
temps la salle parce que je vais le
faire trois cent mille fois chez
quelques tests en termes de photos
vidéos je trouve qu'il est il fonctionne
vraiment bien donc assez sont là la
caméra avant ce classique ça mange bien
ils auront dû vraiment bien la lumière
est vraiment bien bien prise ça c'est le
mode portrait mise à part le fait que
j'ai une tronche horrible dessus ça
détour extrêmement
bien c'est toujours super bien ça
fonctionne très très bien cette concert
avec lust un dragon 845 tasse et capteur
arrière
bon là je les joue un petit peu petit
bras parce que c'est un peu à contre
jour donc forcément et ça c'est
également la caméra arrière ça
fonctionne bien trouve que le rendu
photo et viendra effectivement là c'est
un petit peu très très très rapidement
je suis coach mais c'est des choses
qu'on verra plus en détails en 2019
quand il sera disponible les caméras de
derrière comme ça je retourne en but et
sarah qui en train de travailler ça va
ça se passe bien pour toi alors il est
relou la gamme sont les films et la
boîte en même temps qu'une pleine
chaussée
c'est un petit test vidéo sur la caméra
devant ballon pour ce rapide prise en
main n'a dû me mx3 directement chez
hopscotch
tout coule franchement je trouve qu'il
ya une vraie sensation de solidité de
robustesse de parce ce qu'ils tirent as
toujours un peu las la question tant d
des nouvelles techno comme ça qui arrive
nous présente c'est bien mais est-ce
quel usage c'est intéressant c'est un
usage un peu rapide un tourné en trois
quarts d'heure une heure rapidement mais
néanmoins il ya une vraie belle
sensation de de robustesse de ce côté là
je ça donne trois ça rassure c'est
plutôt pas mal
packaging coule toujours hyper hyper
cali sur cette gamme mimiques sur lui
mx2 et franchement voilà c'est un peu le
même type de goual c'était vraiment
hyper hyper kelly et puis on trouve
vraiment les codes de chez omis de
double module photo ici capteur
d'empreinte digitale au dos voilà je
trouve bien bien réussi s'il vous
intéresse malheureusement il va falloir
attendre encore un petit peu parce que
la version globale n'est pas dispo si
maintenant ça vous dérange pas de parler
anglais ou si vous parler le chinois bas
vous pouvez vous le procurer je vous ai
mis un lien bas dans la description
sinon je donne rendez vous très
rapidement parce qu'on va continuer de
parler de firmi comme je vous le disais
il ya d'autres produits que j'ai foutu
je ne sais plus où pas bon ça le met
creux où décidément tu me saoules ce mec
il au delà 1008 pro qui est là d'ici
quelques jours assure un test ça va être
vraiment vraiment cool pire mon avis il
ya plein de belles promesses à
l'intérieur le 1008 light également donc
vous invite à faire une seule chose à
faire deux choses la première chose
c'est d'aller consulter les playlists
pour savoir quel smartphone choisir son
pari
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
smartphones et qu'un deuxième chose
c'est pour suivre toute l'actu de chiens
au mipi de tous les autres on s'abonne
voilà merci soyez ça je vous embrasse
salut sahara à bientôt une mot de la fin
c'est pour toi là bientôt
voilà c'est hyper efficace